how do people play like this this feels
so bad there are some pros out there or
sick freaks as I like to call them who
tilt their keyboards to a certain degree
that's quite frankly obscene to a more
untrained eye this looks ridiculous and
painful but apparently some people swear
by tilted keyboard setups so like I can
play like this and I have this much I
know a lot of people use their keyboards
horizontally but I see that as a
disadvantage because I can reach a lot
more keys easier in my opinion if I have
my keyboard vertically like with my
thumb I can reach all the way down to
like the end of my keywords now I don't
know about you guys but maybe there is
something to this but let's be real here
I don't care how comfortable you are
turning your keyboard upside down to
play is still cursed your keyboard's
upside down my god dude what the